AstraZeneca
may be able to help.
>> FOR DECADES, AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN GETTING FATTER AND FATTER.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN IS THE
QUESTION.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN TRYING
TO IMPROVE OUR HEALTH FOR A LONG
TIME.
THEY ISSUE DIETARY GOOD NIGHT
LINES.
IF YOU FOLLOW THEM, YOU GET THIN
AND HEALTHY, RIGHT?
ONE LOOK CAREFULLY AT THE GUIDE
LINES HAS CONCLUDED THAT THEY
MADE THINGS WORSE BECAUSE THEY
WERE WRONG.
AND SANYA, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> THIS SEEMS LIKE A STORY THAT
EVERYONE WOULD BE -- IT'S LIKE A
SCANDAL, A BIG SCANDAL.
GOVERNMENT DIETARY GUIDELINES
HAVE THE OPPOSITE EFFECT OF WHAT
THEY SAID THEY WOULD.
IF TRUE, HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> A CONTROVERSIAL SUBJECT WHICH
IS WHY YOU DON'T HEAR MORE ABOUT
IT.
THE REALITY IS, OBESITY IN
AMERICA CONTINUES AT A LOW RATE
UNTIL 1980.
THEN IT TURNED SHARPLY UPWARDS.
WHAT HAPPENED IN 1980?
IN 1980 IS WHEN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT LAUNCHED THE DIETARY
GUIDELINES FOR ALL AMERICANS.
THEY TOLD EVERYBODY IN AMERICA
TO EAT OVER 50% OF THEIR
CALORIES MAINLY AS GRAINS.
RIGHT?
GRAINS FATTENED CATTLE.
TURNS OUT THAT EATING 7 TO 11
SERVINGS OF BREAD EVERY DAY HAS
PROVEN TO BE FATTENING TO
AMERICANS.
>> YEAH.
DELICIOUS THOUGH.
>> WE HAVE THIS FOLLY FOR 40
YEARS NOW.
AND THE CONVENTIONAL ARGUMENT
FOR WHY WE'RE FAT AND DIABETIC
AS A NATION NOW IS WE DON'T
FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES.
IT'S THE FAULT OF AMERICANS FOR
FAILING TO FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES
AND NOT DOING ENOUGH EXERCISE.
WE LOOK AT THE BEST GOVERNMENT
DATA.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THAT AMERICANS
HAVE REALLY FAITHFULLY FOLLOWED
THE GUIDELINES IN EVERY
CATEGORY.
RED MEAT IS DOWN 28%.
ANIMAL FATS DOWN 20%.
WHOLE MILK DOWN 79%.
WE HAVE INCREASED EVERYTHING
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO INCREASE.
WE EAT 25% MORE VEGETABLES, 35%
MORE FRUIT.
28% MORE GRAINS.
87% MORE POLY UNSATURATED
VEGETABLE OILS AS WE'VE BEEN
TOLD.
ON EXERCISE SIDE, MORE THAN 54%
OF AMERICANS MEET THE FOOD
GUIDELINES, WHICH IS UP 44% IN
2005.
SO IN FACT, AMERICANS ARE DOING
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
THEY'RE EXERCISES MORE --
>> FOLLOWING INSTRUCTIONS.
BUT THE INSTRUCTIONS ARE WRONG.
AMAZING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
IT'S JUST LIKE -- UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE OUT OF TIME BUT YOU